KNOW.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
FROM THE MOMENT HE CAME DOWN
THAT SHINY ESCALATOR IN
TRUMP TOWER, DONALD TRUMP
REPRESENTED AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO THE D.C. SWAMP.
HE PROMISED TO END THE CYCLE
OF CORRUPTION THROUGHOUT THE
GOVERNMENT, TO MAKE IT
LEANER AND MORE ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE PEOPLE.
AND HE EVEN TOOK ON SOME OF
THE SACRED COWS.
>> YOU TRUST INTELLIGENCE?
>> NOT SO MUCH FROM THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN DOING
IT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
I MEAN, LOOK WHAT'S HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST 10 YEARS.
I MEAN, IT'S BEEN
CATASTROPHIC.
JUST USE THEM, USE THEM, USE
THEM.
VERY EASY TO USE THEM.
I WON'T USE THEM BECAUSE
THEY HAVE MADE SUCH BAD
DECISIONS.
>> Laura: YEAH, HE HAD THE
NERVE TO CALL OUT THE INTEL
COMMUNITY AKA DEEP STATE AS
PART OF THE PROBLEM.
TRUMP BELIEVED THAT
EVERYTHING IN WASHINGTON HAD
BECOME POLITICIZED, BLOATED,
AND UNMANAGEABLE.
COMMITTEE MEMO THAT WAS
RELEASED TODAY IS THAT
DONALD TRUMP, ONCE AGAIN,
WAS RIGHT.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THEY
SHOULD HAVE FAITH THAT THE
AGENCY'S LEADERSHIP USED
THEIR VAST POWERS WITHOUT
POLITICAL BIAS OR ANIMUS.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
INVESTIGATE OR SURVEIL ANY
AMERICAN WITHOUT CLEAR
AND BY THE WAY, IN ORDER TO
SECURE A FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE
ACT OR FISA WARRANT, THE
GOVERNMENT MUST ALSO FIND
THAT THE PERSON TARGETED IN
THIS CASE, MR. CARTER PAGE,
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THIS,
FBI EVEN MET THAT BENCHMARK.
NOW, APPARENTLY, THOSE
REQUIREMENTS, THOSE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS WENT
OUT THE WINDOW BECAUSE THEY
HAD TO TAKE OUT TRUMP BY ANY
MEANS NECESSARY.
THE AFOREMENTIONED MR. PAGE
IN AN ATTEMPT TO PENETRATE'S
TRUMP INNER CIRCLE.
NOW, PAGE HAS BEEN ON THE
FBI'S RADAR FOR HIS
ACTIVITIES IN RUSSIA LONG
BEFORE HIS NAME WAS LISTED
IN THAT CAMPAIGN IN THE
SPRING OF 2016.
BUT THEN ON OCTOBER 21st,
2016, THE FBI FILED AN
APPLICATION WITH THE FISA
PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER
CREATED BY BRITISH SPY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AS THEIR
PRIMARY EVIDENCE.
NOW, THE DOCUMENT ITSELF WAS
FILLED WITH CONJECTURE AND
UNSUBSTANTIATED ASSERTIONS
ABOUT RUSSIAN EFFORTS TO
COZY UP TO THEN BUSINESSMAN
AND NOW CANDIDATE DONALD
TRUMP.
NOW, WE HAVE KNOWN FOR SOME
TIME THAT THE DOSSIER WAS
FUNDED BY THE DNC AND THE
IT, TOO.
BUT HERE'S THE RUB.
EVEN THOUGH THEY KNEW THE
POLITICAL ORIGINS OF THE
DOSSIER, THE FBI DID NOT
THEY WOULD GO ON TO SECURE
THREE FISA SURVEILLANCE
RENEWALS ON CARTER PAGE.
ALL BASED ON THAT SAME
DOSSIER UOPO RESEARCH IN
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY,
DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
AND DEPUTY A.G. ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
THERE ARE SO MANY LAPSES AND
BIASES AT PLAY HERE IT'S SO
HARD TO KEEP TRACK OF THEM
BUT WE ARE GOING TO DO OUR
BEST.
WE KNOW THE FBI AUTHORIZED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, FOR
SOURCE WHEN IT CAME TO
OFFICIALS THAT HE WAS,
QUOTE, DESPERATE THAT DONALD
TRUMP NOT GET ELECTED AND
WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT HIM NOT
BEING PRESIDENT.
NO AGENDA THERE WHATSOEVER.
SO HE COOKS UP THIS FAKE
DOSSIER SO TRY TO KILL
TRUMP'S CANDIDACY.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, STEELE
BEGAN SHOOTING HIS MOUTH OFF
TO YAHOO NEWS ABOUT CARTER
PAGE'S TRIP TO MOSCOW, WHICH
INCLUDED HIS INFAMOUS
DOSSIER.
THE FBI LATER CITES THAT
YAHOO NEWS STORY AS
THAT'S A NEAT TRICK.
A STORY ABOUT THE DOSSIER IS
CORROBORATION OF THE STORY
THE BUREAU PUT ALL OF THAT
IN THEIR FISA REQUEST TO
CONTINUE THEIR SURVEILLANCE
STEELE'S DOSSIER AND THE
FAKE NEWS HE LEAKED TO GET
THE FISA WARRANT, THEY
REALIZED STEELE IS LEAKING
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION TO
THE MEDIA AND DIVULGING HIS
RELATIONSHIP TO THE FBI.
SO THE FBI TERMINATED ITS
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIM.
SO HERE'S THE UPSHOT.
THE PREDICATE FOR THE ENTIRE
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION CAN
NORTHWARD, THE PREVAILING
EVIDENCE ADVANCED TO SURVEIL
PAGE WHICH WOULD LEAD TO THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION AND
ALL THE MADNESS THAT
FOLLOWED WAS BUILT ON THE
FOUNDATION OF THE FAKE
STEELE DOSSIER PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN
AND THE DNC HERE IS DEVIN
NUNES A SHORT TIME AGO.
>> JUST STEP BACK FOR A
MOMENT.
THIS IS NOT GOING AFTER SOME
TERRORIST.
THEN THEY GOT A WARRANT ON
SOMEONE IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, USING OPPOSITION
RESEARCH PAID FOR BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
IT IS WRONG AND SHOULD NEVER
BE DONE.
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS WHO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, FUNNY THEY
THEY CAN NEVER BE
QUESTIONED.
THEY ARE ALWAYS RIGHT.
BUT THE LEFT DID SOUND LIKE
>> EACH OF THESES
ALLEGATIONS IS AT BEST
CHERRY PICKED AND AT WORSE
JUST SIMPLY NOT AT ALL
INDICATIVE OF THE BIAS THAT
THE REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING
TO ALLEGE.
>> LIKELY CHERRY PICKED AND
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
APPLICATION CHERRY PICK TWO
POINTS YOU DON'T LIKE.
>> WHY SHOULD THE FBI AND
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
TRUST OUR COMMITTEE
SENSITIVE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION THEY THINK WE
ARE ON A PARTY LINE BASIS
GOING TO VOTE TO CHERRY PICK
AND DISCLOSE PARTS OF IT.
>> Laura: THAT'S LIKE A
DRINKING GAME ON A FRIDAY
NIGHT CHERRY PICK.
YOU WILL BE REALLY TRASHED.
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, REMEMBER,
WAS SUPPOSEDLY THE CONCERN
THAT DROVE THE FBI TO APPLY
FOR THAT SURVEILLANCE
WARRANT.
THEY WORRIED THAT THE
ELECTION WOULD BE
THAT THIS SURVEILLANCE
ITSELF WAS DESIGNED TO
AS AN INSURANCE POLICY
AGAINST TRUMP'S WINNING.
LATER AS AN EFFORT TO UNDO
THE ELECTION AND UPEND THE
PRESIDENCY.
ALL.
YOU BET.
THE COLLUSION WAS BETWEEN
THE COMEY FBI, THE OBAMA